Gentlemen,
[Silence]
alhamdulillah.
continuing in
the book of fasting
in the chapter
Regarding the pillars of fasting,
we mentioned that there are how many
pillars to fasting?
Two. The first one,
intention. The second,
refraining from anything that will break
a person's fast. And how many things
break a person's fast?
six or five, however you however you
list them.
We mentioned thus far three of them.
Number one and two are
eating and drinking anything
you know purposely.
Number three which we discussed
yesterday
is inducing oneself to vomit. Okay.
The fourth and fifth areas
the menration or postpartum
bleeding.
So these two things menration and
postpartum.
Menration is a monthly cycle obviously
and postpartum is exactly what it sounds
post meaning afterartum child
birth. So when a woman gives birth there
is a cleansing that occurs to the womb
and there is a bleeding that takes
place and as
mentioned this will never continue past
40 days. Anything past 40 days, it may
be postpartum medically, but in the
legislation of Islam, for our intents
and purposes, Islam no longer views this
as postpartum bleeding anymore.
So
these two things, ministration and
postpartum bleeding, these are two
things that have the same rulings all
through Islamic legislation
except in three instances.
Outside of these three instances, what
is said for
postpartum is said for is true for
menration and what is said for menration
is true for postpartum bleeding. These
two things are one of the or two of the
things that will compromise a woman's
fast. So if a woman is having her cycle
or experiencing postpartum then this
will
this woman is relieved from fasting
during this period. She is relieved from
fasting during this period and she is to
make up these days that she misses
when she is finished with her cycle or
when she is finished with her postpartum
bleeding.
He says
five and four and five are menration
and postpartum.
Even if it happens at the very end of
the day, even if it happens just before,
just before the aden, as soon as a
woman's cycle begins or as soon as
postpartum bleeding begins, which is
less spontaneous,
then fasting now is no longer
obligated upon her at this time until
she is finished with this and so at any
time when she begins her cycle
throughout the day this will immediately
nullify the fast for the day. So the
question now is
let's say a person
has
an excuse to break their fast.
Can they freely
eat and drink in the daytime of Ramadan
or should it be just fasting but
not really fasting my fast is not
is I'm not really fasting but I'm not
really indulging as if I wasn't fasting.
The answer is you're either fasting or
you're not. Those are the two. There's
no in between. I'm kind of fasting, I'm
a little bit fasting, a partial fasting.
This doesn't exist. And the same thing
goes with a person who has
an excuse to break his fast and then
that excuse is over during the daytime
of fasting. Let's say a person is
traveling
and they arrive home midday.
Do they have to refrain
and complete their day fasting even
though it is not considered to be a
valid fast? They will have to make it
up. The answer and the correct opinion
is the fatwa of Abdullahbdah.
He said whoever
has an allowance to break his fast in
the in the beginning of the day then he
is to break his fast at the end of the
day. There's no difference. A day of
fasting is one unit. If a person has an
excuse to break his fast, let's say a
person is traveling and he arrives home
30 minutes after fud and he is not
fasting of that day. Does he have to do
what is referred to by some of the fukah
as im which is to refrain from anything
eating or drinking until the sundown?
The answer is no. This person had a
valid
legislative allowance to break his fast.
Therefore, he is not fasting that day.
When does this issue of imac take place?
This takes place in instances when a
person does not have an allowance to
break his fast at the beginning of the
day. Right? Let's say for instance, a
person
doesn't know that it's Ramadan until
midday, right? They've already eaten.
They've already drank and then they find
out, oh, it's actually Ramadan. Ramadan
started. Can they continue to eat and
drink throughout the day? No. They
immediately
stop and complete their day, but they
have to make that day up. Why is that?
Why are you fasting even though your
fast is invalid?
This is because it is a sacred time,
right? And this person didn't have an
allowance at the beginning of the day.
And this is exactly what the prophet
sallall.aii wasallam commanded
in Sah Muslim. The prophet
sallallah.aii alaihi wasallam
sent
people to go through Medina and inform
everyone that is now obligatory to fast.
Whoever has not eaten nor drank anything
for the day then he is to continue his
fast and whoever has eaten or drank
anything then he is to begin his fast
from this moment. Right? And so he
commanded them to stop eating and
drinking even though it was midday
before before a zoed. So this is the
difference between these two. But if a
person has an allowance to fast
at the beginning of the day, then he has
an allowance to fast at the end. It goes
as one unit.
Now, should a woman who is on her cycle
or during postpartum, you know, if she
has little kids that are easily confused
be, you know, walking around the house
telling them fast, but then she's like
eating and drinking maybe for the sake
of confusion. This is something that is
not preferred, right?
so that the children don't become
don't misunderstand or what have you.
However, if a person has a valid
allowance, then they are allowed to
indulge freely.
The sixth and final
thing that will nullify
that will compromise a person's fast is
elim
which is
intercourse
right and intercourse actually has a
bare minimum that the prophet sallallah
alaii wasallam quantified
which we will discuss us
inshallah
this is considered to be a major sin
in Islam for a person to engage in
intercourse
without an allowance during the daytime
of Ramadan. Then this is a major sin in
Islam and it has the most strict kafur
that there is and that is that in order
to expedate this a person must fast two
consecutive
months without breaking a single day in
between and if they break a single day
in between they have to start over
again. This is a very very very
weighty
kafur experation. And so the
punishments or the experations for a
particular act they reflect the
seriousness of the act itself
which we will get into inshallah.
Now this is also
back to what we said in the previous
and that is if a person has an Islamic
allowance person has an allowance to
break his fast. A man and his wife are
traveling they get home in midday.
would this apply to them? Are they
prohibited from engaging in intercourse?
No. Because you're as we mentioned
you're either fasting or you're not
right. The only time a person ha does
what is called imse which is to refrain
even though the person is not fasting is
if they do not have an allowance to
break their fast. They do not have a in
this instance. their recourse is to
immediately cease anything that would
break their fast. He then cites
a narration on the authority of Abi. The
narration is in Bkari, a Muslim. It's in
Malik and it's also in a
very well-known narration. It's in all
three
save.
[Silence]
Abu said, "Once we were sitting with the
prophet Sam
when a man approached and said,
Oh messenger of Allah, I am done. I'm
totally done. I'm finished.
He said, "What is the problem?"
He said, "I
had intercourse with my wife while I
was fasting.
He said, "Do you
possess a slave that you could free as
an expeation?" A person may say, "Well,
you mentioned that this is such a major
sin in Islam. Why didn't the prophet
sallallahu alaihi wasallam point that
out? Why didn't he say this is a major
sin that you have committed?" A man
comes and says, "I'm done. I'm finished.
There's no hope for me. Do you need to
tell him, "Hey, by the way, this is a
major sin in Islam." He's already got
the message. We're past that. Right now,
we're at the point of recourse. He's
learned the lesson. He knows that this
is wrong. We don't need to add on to his
despair. And so the messenger of Allah
sallallah.aii alaihi wasallam said, "Do
you possess a slave that you could free?
All freeing of slaves which act as an
expeation, the slave must be Muslim."
This would not work for a non-Muslim
slave. And this and the same goes with
feeding.
Any charity that is obligatory as an
expeation must be to a Muslim, a
non-Muslim for optional
charity. But an obligatory charity must
go to a Muslim if it is an expeation. So
for instance feeding you know 10 poor
people for for breaking one's vow. These
poor people are to be Muslim right there
is a difference. This is in obligatory
experations.
He says
no I don't.
He said, "Then are you able to fast two
consecutive months?"
These are two consecutive lunar months,
which means that they would never be
more than 60 days. And they have to be
consecutive,
which means that if a person were to not
break, not fast for one of those days,
fail to fast, they have to restart this
from the beginning. very serious, very
difficult, not easy at all.
He said, "No." In another wording of
this narration, he said, "Fasting is
what I wasn't able to do in the first
place. I wasn't able to do one day and
get through it. How could I possibly do
two months?" He said,
he said, "Then are you able to feed 60
poor people?"
That number 60, why 60? Why 60 poor
people?
Two months. Yeah. Two months. 60 poor
people. Two months. Right. But notice
what what the what it started with.
It started with freeing a slave.
Why? Because that's good for the slave.
With respect to slavery, we'll finish
this narration tomorrow inshallah. With
respect to slavery in the time of the
prophet sallallah.aii wasallam before
his time in Jahyah,
slavery was a funnel.
Imagine a funnel.
There was a very wide entrance.
Anything could make you a slave. You
could get kidnapped. You could give your
kids up for debt. You could be have a
gambling problem and trade your kids
over for that. You could sell your
children into slavery. You could get
taken as a prisoner of war. You could
get lost in the desert and picked up by
some shady characters. But the point is
is that all kinds of things would make
you a slave. But there's only one way
that you could be emancipated.
What is that way?
Huh?
That your that the master emancipates
you. Even if you had all the money in
the world, the money belongs to him
immediately. A slave's money belongs to
his master. And hypothetically,
if
someone were to come and say, "I will
purchase this slave for from you for a
trillion dollars."
And the slave master decides, "No, I
don't want to. He cannot be forced to do
that or compelled." which is why Abuak
was considered to be so dutiful in
purchasing the Muslim slaves that were
accepting Islam and being punished by
their masters. Bil was one of them. He
tried to purchase Bil many many times
for a long time but he was taken as a
personal project by his masters to be
tortured.
Right? So the point is is that those
were the rules that they played by.
Islam
came and flipped the funnel around.
So now there's only one way to end up as
a slave. But there are many, many, many
ways to be freed, to be emancipated,
only one way a person can legitimately
end up as a slave. What is that way?
Prisoner of war. You're taken on the
battlefield
fighting actively trying to kill Muslim
men on the battlefield. You'll take as a
prisoner of war. And no, we don't have a
big camp to put you in for us to sink
resources into keeping you around. Nope.
We'll divide them up as slaves and we'll
get some use out of them. Right? And so
this was the only way a person would
become a slave. But to be emancipated
many many many many ways. And one of
those ways is if the slave is able to
buy his freedom. The slave master must
concede unless this is you know unless
there are dubious reasons behind it.
meaning is some kind of criminal that if
he were to be, you know, emancipated,
he would he would be bad for society.
Other than that, he must concede. And as
a matter of fact, Allah made it
obligatory upon the Muslim collectively
to pay zaka to be able to free slaves
that want their emancipation. But not
all slaves wanted to be emancipated. As
a matter of fact, an argument could be
made that it was
a lot of times better to remain a slave
than it would be to be emancipated
because you eat, you drink, you have
shelter, you're dressed, you have
quarters to live in, you you're set.
You're set. You don't have to go make
your own way. We will stop there.
Inshallah we'll conclude this narration
tomorrow.
[Silence]
No, it applies to both.
[Arabic recitation]
a we'll talk about that tomorrow.
I'll bring it up tomorrow.